vous l'avez peut-être déjà croisé sur le
port de saint pierre ni à pied ni sur un
bateau mais en équilibre sur son
deux-roues randol boulangier et ancien
champion de la réunion de vtt trial vice
champion de france en 2003 il a aussi
déjà participé au championnat du monde
après avoir organisé des compétitions à
la réunion puis lâché la faire faute de
compétiteur il roule maintenant en solo
pour ses sponsors aurait pour son
plaisir rencontré démonstration de ce
sport extrême tout en équilibre est en
délicatesse c'est maintenant
alors ça a commencé il ya quinze ans à
peu près
donc je suis allé à une au trial indoor
au stade de l'est à saint-denis et
j'étais parti voir la compétition de
moto et vélo et à la fin de la soirée y
avait une tombola et
sur 3500 entrées il y avait un vélo à
gagner ils ont tiré vous en tirez le
ticket et puis c'est moi qui l'ait gagné
j'ai commencé comme
à l'origine j'ai commencé sur le spot de
manapany débat donc c'est typiquement un
coin naturel je dirais et donc je suis
plus tentés à travailler sur du naturel
mais c'est vrai que des fois j'aime bien
faire un peu d'artificiel parce que
laure et ça change tout et pas un thé
pas tout seul et puis il ya autant de
plaisir à rouler sur de l'artificiel
également
alors fait c'est un sport qui consiste à
passer des obstacles soient artificielle
soit naturel donc l'objectif c'est de
les passer le plus propre possible
donc l'objectif lui également c'est de
permettre le prix par terre donc il faut
faire des gestes d'avant en arrière
d'autant bas donc 5 ça implique d'avoir
de l'equilibre beaucoup de concentration
et après il suffit juste de prendre soin
c'est un petit peu comme
gérer la perche donc tu as droit à
quelques essais et puis tu essayes they
say they say à un moment ça passe encore
ça passe pas il faut repasser un petit
peu plus bas mais après tes sensations
c'est surtout toujours essayé de
dépasser la marche l'obstacle est
soi-même quoi
alors ce qui est sympa c'est que ya pas
mal de mobilier urbain donc
il ya différentes hauteurs il ya
suffisamment d'espacé entre autres
chaque chaque au module donc je monte
aussi bien sur des murs et sur des murs
un peu plus droit également je passe sur
des barrières dont il ya vraiment des
choses sympas à faire après ce qui est
bien c'est qu'il ya toujours et toujours
du soleil et puis c'est très très très
très vert aussi au tour donc c'est assez
sympa surtout il ya beaucoup de public
oui
il faut surtout déjà très motivés parce
que ça s'apprend avec des années il faut
avoir un moral vraiment trempées et
surtout vraiment s'investir quoi on va
dire 3 à 4 heures minimum par semaine
pour vraiment monter assez vite et puis
il faut s'attendre à casser un petit peu
de le vélo au début des petites pièces
donc quand même avoir un certain un
certain investissement